This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1883, Samuel Clemens, alias Mark Twain, published his memoir, Life on the Mississippi. In it, Twain describes his love for the Great River and how it captured his imagination from boyhood. In fact, the pen name Mark Twain is probably a reference to what a deckhand on a Mississippi riverboat would call out to indicate a depth of two vathos. These are recordings from a real steamboat worker from 1939. Twain. Twain would have heard this call many times. As a young man, he worked as a steamboat pilot on the Mississippi. This was a job that required him to learn everything there is to know about the river.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1883年，化名马克·吐温的塞缪尔·克莱门斯出版了他的回忆录《密西西比河上的生活》。在书中，吐温描述了他对这条大河的热爱，以及它如何从他的少年时代起就俘获了他的想象力。事实上，“马克·吐温”这个笔名很可能是指密西西比河轮船上的水手用来表示两英寻水深的呼喊。这些是1939年真实轮船工人的录音。吐温。吐温一定听过很多次这样的呼喊。年轻时，他曾在密西西比河上当过轮船领航员。这份工作要求他掌握关于这条河的一切。
That's Orion Kailoth. He's a reporter at New Orleans Public Radio. Working on steamboats, Twain would come to memorize every shawl, bend, rock, island, bluff-freef, wind-reaf, eddy, snag, sandbar, and he would learn how all those things changed when the river was high or when it was low, and calm breezes, high winds at night time and daytime. Twain wrote, The Face of the Water became a wonderful book. There never was a wonderful book written by a man. Mark Twain loved working on the river, but he found it came with a price.
那是奥里恩·凯洛斯。他是新奥尔良公共广播电台的记者。在轮船上工作时，吐温渐渐记住了每一处浅滩、河湾、礁石、岛屿、峭壁、风脊、回水湾、暗桩、沙洲，他还了解了当水位上涨、下降、微风徐徐、昼夜起风时，所有这些事物是如何变化的。吐温写道：“水面变成了一本奇妙的书。从来没有一本书能由人写得如此精彩。”马克·吐温热爱在河上的工作，但他发现这也是有代价的。
As he gained knowledge about the workings of the Mississippi, he began to lose something too. His sense of wonder about the great river. Twain writes about this in his memoir. I had lost something which could never be restored to me while I lived. All the grace, the beauty, the poetry, had gone out of the majestic river. But not everyone had such a complicated relationship with the river. For many people who lived near the Mississippi, it was simple.
随着他对密西西比河运作机制的了解加深，他也开始失去一些东西。他对这条大河的惊奇感。吐温在他的回忆录中写到了这一点：“我失去了某些东西，只要我还活着，就永远无法找回。所有的优雅、美丽、诗意，都已经从这条雄伟的河中消失了。”但并非所有人都与这条河有着如此复杂的关系。对于许多住在密西西比河附近的人来说，一切很简单。
The river was a force to be reckoned with. When you're talking about the Mississippi River, to me it's not something scenic. It's this great force of enormous power. This is John Barry, an expert on the river's history. He served on the levee board of New Orleans, and has written extensively about the Mississippi. And the thing to know about the river, especially back then, was that it flooded all the time. A river flood, or at least, on a flood like the Mississippi. You can see it coming for weeks.
这条河是一股不可忽视的力量。当你谈论密西西比河时，对我来说，它不是什么风景优美的地方。它是拥有巨大力量的伟大自然力。这是约翰·巴里，一位河流历史专家。他曾在新奥尔良堤防委员会任职，并撰写了大量关于密西西比河的文章。关于这条河，尤其是当年，必须要知道的一点是，它一直在泛滥。河水泛滥，或者至少像密西西比河这样规模的洪水。你可以提前几周看到它涌来。
You fight it for weeks. And in 1927, people knew the river was coming for them. For nine straight months, the middle of the country had been getting hit nearly non-stop with rain. And the previous winter, there had been tremendous snowfall upriver in Minnesota, which was now washing downstream. The levees were strained.
你要与之抗争数周。而在1927年，人们知道河水正向他们涌来。在连续九个月的时间里，美国中部几乎不间断地下着雨。而前一个冬天，上游的明尼苏达州下了巨大的雪，现在这些雪正在顺流而下。堤防承受着巨大的压力。
And in February of 1927, they started giving out. 27 flood was probably worse than Katrina. Roughly a million Americans, almost 1% of the entire population of the country at the time, were flooded out of their homes. That spring, 145 levees along the Lower River failed. 27,000 square miles across 10 states were put underwater. It's unclear how many people died, because for one thing, official counts didn't include black people.
在1927年2月，它们开始垮塌。1927年的洪水可能比卡特里娜飓风还要糟糕。大约有两百万美国人——几乎占当时全国总人口的1%——因洪水被迫离开家园。那年春天，下游沿岸的145处堤防溃决。10个州的27000平方英里土地被水淹没。目前还不清楚有多少人死亡，因为一方面，官方统计并未将黑人计算在内。
But the death toll was likely upwards of a thousand. On April 30, 1927, then Secretary of Commerce Herbert Hoover discussed the flood on a national radio broadcast. Everything humanly possible is being done by men of magnificent courage and skill. It is a battle against the oncoming rush. It is a great battle, which the engineers are directing. And you've got to remember, this was enormous news.
但死亡人数可能超过一千人。1927年4月30日，时任商务部长赫伯特·胡佛在全国广播节目中讨论了这场洪水。具有非凡勇气和技巧的人们正在竭尽全力做到人类所能做到的一切。这是一场对抗汹涌洪流的战斗。这是一场伟大的战斗，由工程师们指挥。你必须记住，这是一个巨大的轰动性新闻。
It dominated the front pages. Lindbergh flew across the Atlantic and the middle of the flood, that's the only thing that knocked it off the top of the news and after the flight, the flood was back on. In the wake of the flood, Congress essentially declared war on the Mississippi River by passing a law called the Flood Control Act of 1928. A part of the 28 act involves studying basically every major river basin. A river basin is all the land that water flows through on its way to a river. So for example, if it rains in South Dakota, anywhere in the whole state, that rain will eventually make its way to the Mississippi,
它占据了各大报纸的头版。林德伯格在洪水肆虐期间飞越大西洋，那是唯一一件将洪水挤下头条的事，而飞行结束后，洪水又回到了头条。在洪水过后，国会通过了一项名为《1928年防洪法》的法律，实质上向密西西比河流域宣战。1928年法案的一部分内容涉及研究基本上每一个主要的流域。流域是指水在流向河流的过程中流经的所有土地。因此，例如，如果在南达科他州下雨，无论是在该州的什么地方，这雨最终都会流入密西西比河，
which means that South Dakota is part of the Mississippi River basin, even though it's actually pretty far from the Mississippi River. In 1928, Congress decided to study rivers and their basins, especially the Mississippi and its enormous basin, which includes more than 30 states. And not just study them, but also change them. The Flood Control Act charged the US Army Corps of Engineers with designing and executing a plan to corral and maneuver the Mississippi. To better manage its ebbs and flows so that future disasters could be averted. But the Army Corps of Engineers faced a dilemma. The river control system that they had been tasked with creating needed to be huge, much bigger than anything they'd ever built before, and they didn't want to just jump into building something until they
这意味着南达科他州是密西西比河流域的一部分，尽管它实际上离密西西比河相当远。1928年，国会决定研究河流及其流域，尤其是密西西比河及其包含30多个州的庞大流域。不仅要研究它们，还要改变它们。《防洪法》授权美国陆军工程兵团设计并实施一项计划，以围堵和调控密西西比河。以便更好地管理其涨落，从而避免未来的灾难。但陆军工程兵团面临着一个两难境地。他们被委派创建的河流控制系统需要非常巨大，比他们以前建造过的任何东西都要大得多，而且在他们
knew it would work. They started constructing scale models of different parts of the Mississippi River basin in order to understand the mechanics of the river. The earliest ones were just ditches cut into the dirt with water running through them. The models helped forecast flooding in St. Louis, the impact of a dam construction in Ohio, the workings of spillways in New Orleans and Florida. But the Army Corps of Engineers wanted a way to test the entire river system all at once, and so in 1941, they started building a model to represent all 1.25 million square
确信它能行之有效之前，他们不想贸然建造任何东西。他们开始建造密西西比河流域不同部分的比例模型，以了解河流的力学原理。最早的模型只是在泥土中挖出水沟，让水流过。这些模型帮助预测了圣路易斯的洪水、俄亥俄州大坝建设的影响，以及新奥尔良和佛罗里达溢洪道的运作。但陆军工程兵团希望找到一种方法，一次性测试整个河流系统，因此在1941年，他们开始建造一个代表密西西比河流域全部125万平方
miles of the Mississippi River Basin. When you think of a scale model, you might be thinking of something you can peer into at a museum. Not so with this one. This would be bigger than anything that could ever fit into a display case. The Mississippi Basin model, located just outside of Jackson, Mississippi, is a scale replica of the entire basin region, an area that spans from Appalachia to the Rocky Mountains, nearly half of the continental United States.
英里的模型。当你想到比例模型时，你可能会想到在博物馆里可以窥视的东西。这个模型可不是这样。它将比任何能放入展示柜的东西都要大。位于密西西比州杰克逊市郊外的密西西比流域模型，是整个流域地区的等比例复制品，该地区从阿巴拉契亚山脉延伸至落基山脉，几乎占了美国本土的一半。
I went out to see the model with a woman named Janey Vaughn. She used to work at the model as a technician before it was decommissioned in the early 90s. Janey showed me how to sneak in, right through a wall of poison ivy. And I just always assume that any snakes will, you know, kind of run off. We're also there with former project engineer Wayne O'Neill. I'm Wayne O'Neill, glad to meet you. Now that we've made it through the IV, we make our way to this enormous clearing. And this is the beautiful Mississippi River Basin, Mississippi Basin model. Wow.
我和一个叫简妮·沃恩的女人一起去参观了这个模型。在90年代初该模型退役之前，她曾在该模型担任技术员。简妮向我展示了如何潜入，直接穿过一堵毒常春藤墙。我总是假设任何蛇都会，你知道的，自己跑开。我们同行的还有前项目工程师韦恩·奥尼尔。我是韦恩·奥尼尔，很高兴见到你。既然我们已经穿过了常春藤，我们便来到这片巨大的开阔地。这就是美丽的密西西比河流域，密西西比流域模型。哇。
In all its glory. Whoa. Ryan is looking down at a three-dimensional map, a completely man-made landscape pool of hills and ridges and a big winding riverbed. Every foot of the model represents 2,000 feet in the real world. If you take a good step, you step off a mile. It's hard to overstate how enormous this model is. It's about two and a half times the size of Disneyland, 125 city blocks.
尽显其壮丽。哇。瑞安正俯视着一个三维地图，这是一个完全由人工建造的丘陵、山脊和一个巨大的蜿蜒河床的景观池。模型的每一英尺代表现实世界中的2000英尺。如果你迈出一大步，你就跨过了一英里。这个模型究竟有多大，怎么形容都不为过。它大约是迪士尼乐园的二点五倍大，有125个城市街区那么大。
I saw some pictures online, but this does not prepare you to see the thing. Yeah, it's awesome, isn't it? It's just awesome. You just can't take it all in at once. Janian Wayne tell me that you can really only see all the edges of it if you climb up this four-story observation tower. There's also a water tower looming above the model, with dozens of pipes shooting off in every direction into pump houses and spigots. These big hulking machines and strange looking instruments dot the landscape. And what they had envisioned when they built this, it was just fantastic.
我在网上看过一些照片，但这并不能让你对亲眼看到这个庞然大物有所准备。是的，它太棒了，不是吗？简直太棒了。你根本无法一眼将它全部收入眼底。简妮和韦恩告诉我，你只有爬上这座四层楼高的观景塔，才能真正看清它的所有边缘。模型上方还有一个高耸的水塔，几十根管道从四面八方射向泵房和水龙头。这些笨重的大型机器和奇怪的仪器点缀着这片景观。当他们建造这个模型时，他们所构想的景象简直太奇妙了。
Back when the model was operational, there were little signs for pretty much every town in the region. Mm-hmm. There would be one for Vicksburg and Rolling Fork and all along. every town in the region. The signs are gone now, but Jaini still knows the geography of this place by heart. We're around Baton Rouge, so you can go from Baton Rouge up to St. Louis in about 10 minutes. The Army Corps of Engineers started work on the Mississippi Basin Model in 1941, and at first they faced a massive labor shortage. The start of the model came by the Civil War II. No labor was available, everybody was off at war, there wasn't troops or people here to do it, so they built a build I became here to supply the labor.
当年该模型投入运营时，该地区的几乎每个城镇都有小标牌。嗯嗯。维克斯堡和罗LLING FORK以及沿途都会有标牌。该地区的每个城镇。标牌现在已经没了，但简妮对这里的地理位置仍然了如指掌。我们在巴吞鲁日附近，所以你可以在大约10分钟内从巴吞鲁日走到圣路易斯。陆军工程兵团于1941年开始着手建造密西西比流域模型，起初他们面临着严重的劳动力短缺。模型的启动正赶上第二次世界大战。没有劳动力可用，每个人都去打仗了，这里没有军队或人手来做这件事，所以他们建造了一个战俘营，我就是来这里提供劳动力的。
German prisoners of war helped with every facet of the construction. And they did the groundwork and the topography layout and the drainage system for the model. By 1949 the model was ready. A staff of 600 engineers and technicians would calibrate the model by recreating past floods in the region. Then they'd forecast new floods. They would run thousands of gallons of water through the model, recording the water's height and movements.
德国战俘参与了建设的方方面面。他们做了基础工作、地形布局和模型的排水系统。到1949年，模型准备就绪。由600名工程师和技术人员组成的团队通过重现该地区过去的大洪水来校准模型。然后他们会预测新的洪水。他们会将数千加仑的水注入模型，记录水的高度和运动。
After it was all done, they'd change a few variables and run it again. More standbags over. Here, open this spillway over there. They played around with the model, gathering data on how each piece of the river system affected the whole. Then, they could use that data to come up with better plans for the future, like they did in 1952, when council bluffs and su city Iowa were threatened with the flood. In 1952, the model predicted where the levees were going to overtop.
这一切完成后，他们会改变几个变量并再次运行。把沙袋再搬过去一点。这里，把那边的溢洪道打开。他们摆弄着模型，收集关于河流系统的各个部分如何影响整体的数据。然后，他们可以使用这些数据来制定未来更好的计划，就像他们在1952年所做的那样，当时爱荷华州的康瑟尔布拉夫斯和苏城面临洪水的威胁。1952年，该模型预测了堤防将在哪里漫顶。
Over top as in where the water would spill over the levee. And so they ran the model night and day as they were fighting the flood. What they were doing is saying it's not going to overtop here. It'll overtop here, put your sandbags, put your work in this area. And it predicted stages within two tenths of a foot. Meaning the model mimicked the actual behavior
漫顶是指水将漫过堤防的地方。因此，在抗洪期间，他们夜以继日地运行模型。他们所做的是说，这里不会漫顶。这里会漫顶，把你们的沙袋放好，把你们的工作放在这个区域。它预测的水位精确到十分之二英尺以内。这意味着模型模拟了密西西比河的实际行为
of the Mississippi to within inches. It was credited to save an over $50 million in damage in 52. That's about half a billion dollars in today's money. The Mississippi Basin model was amazingly accurate at dealing with these incredibly complex, hyper-specific problems. The model saved the government millions and millions of dollars while it was an operation and spared people from the kinds of disastrous flooding that had happened back in 1927. But 200 acres of pipes and pumps and machinery and earth movers and a staff of hundreds were expensive to maintain.
误差在几英寸以内。据信，它在52年减少了超过5000万美元的损失。这相当于今天大约五亿美元的资金。密西西比流域模型在处理这些极其复杂、高度具体的问题时表现得惊人准确。该模型在运行期间为政府节省了数百万美元，并使人们免于遭受1927年那种灾难性的洪水。但是200英亩的管道、水泵、机械、土方机械以及数百名员工的维护成本很高。
The cost got even harder to justify after the advent of the computer. In late 60s, early 70s, there was a big push to go into numerical models. And that means computers. Right. Math model. The numerical model, people and the core looked at the model, says, well, we don't need it anymore. Too expensive. Too expensive.
在计算机问世之后，成本变得更难以证明其合理性。在60年代末、70年代初，人们大力推动转向数值模型。这意味着计算机。没错。数学模型。数值模型人员和工程兵团看着这个模型说，好吧，我们不再需要它了。太贵了。太贵了。
Gradually, the Mississippi Basin model lost its funding. We saw the handwriting on the wall and it was closing its down. The computer models weren't as good, but they were good enough and the Army Corps could not or would not pay for the gigantic river basin model anymore. The model was used in a diminished capacity until 1993 when it was closed for good. Today it's completely derelict. Damn this place is depressing. Didn't it?
渐渐地，密西西比流域模型失去了资金支持。我们看到了大势已趋，它正在关闭。计算机模型虽然没有那么好，但已经足够好了，陆军工程兵团无法也不愿再为这个巨大的河流流域模型支付费用。该模型以缩减的容量一直使用到1993年，当时它被彻底关闭。如今它已完全荒废。该死，这个地方真让人沮丧。不是吗？
Crap. Every time I come out here, it's worse. I know. There's a lot of labor. There's a lot of love and effort and went into this thing and it is just abandoned. I feel like if I was a teenager, this would be my number one come get high and get in trouble spot. Exactly.
废话。每次我来这里，它都变得更糟。我知道。这里倾注了大量的劳动力。这里倾注了大量的爱心和努力，而它现在却被遗弃了。我觉得如果我还是个青少年，这绝对是我首选的吸大麻和惹麻烦的宝地。完全正确。
Exactly. The pipes and the pump houses are all rotting and rusting away. And in the model, the earth and mud and water have all dried up. Now it's just a disheveled mess of concrete and wire mesh. I've seen the original design drawings of this place, those engineers were engineers. I would be doing good to sharpen their pencil. You know, the mines that came up with all those pieces of equipment,
完全正确。管道和泵房都在腐烂生锈。而在模型中，泥土、淤泥和水都已经干涸。现在它只是一团凌乱的混凝土和金属网。我见过这个地方最初的设计图纸，那些工程师才是真正的工程师。我要是能给他们的铅笔削尖就不错了。你知道的，那些想出所有这些设备的人，
with the knowledge they had in the 40s, and they're coming up with ways to protect people and make the stuff work. You just don't see engineering feats like that every day. Now, in a normal public radio story, this would be the part where we would be bonn the death of craftsmanship and remark on all the things we've lost by choosing virtual things over physical ones. But before you get too misty-eyed, you have to see where Jani von works now.
凭借他们在40年代拥有的知识，他们正在想方设法保护人们并让这些东西运转起来。你不会每天都看到这样的工程壮举。现在，在标准的公共广播故事中，这将是我们哀悼工艺的消亡，并感叹我们通过选择虚拟事物而非实体事物而失去的一切的时刻。但在你陷入过于感伤的情绪之前，你必须去看看简妮·沃恩现在在哪里工作。
About two weeks after going to the Basin model, Ryan met Jani at the US Army Engineer Research and Development Center. Erdick, for short, in Vicksburg, Mississippi. I keep forgetting that you actually work for the Army and like badge and the real deal. It's not a joke. Yeah. Walking around Erdick feels like being
去过流域模型大约两周后，瑞安在美国陆军工程兵研发中心见到了简妮。简称埃尔迪克（Erdick），位于密西西比州维克斯堡。我总是忘记你其实为军队工作，还有胸牌和真家伙。这不是开玩笑。是的。在埃尔迪克四处走动感觉就像在
on the back lot of a Hollywood studio. There's row after row of big hangers full of miniature landscapes. There's hangers over there, hangers over there, hangers with model and model and model and model and model just lined up. Engineers zip around in trucks and golf carts. They test all kinds of things here, including a few things that have nothing to do with water. In one hanger, I saw engineers developing a temporary airplane runway. They were driving over it with a modified dump truck on 14-foot tires to simulate the weight of a plane. But mostly, Erdick builds scale models of rivers and dams and water projects. I'll be at smaller, more manageable ones than the Mississippi model.
好莱坞制片厂的后景场里。一排又一排的大机库里摆满了微型景观。那边有机库，那边有机库，有机库里摆满了模型、模型、模型、模型、模型。工程师们开着卡车和高尔夫球车呼啸而过。他们在这里测试各种各样的事情，包括一些与水无关的事情。在一个机库里，我看到工程师们正在开发一条临时飞机跑道。他们开着一辆带有14英尺轮胎的改装自卸卡车碾压它，以模拟飞机的重量。但埃尔迪克主要建造的是河流、大坝和水利工程的比例模型。当然，这些模型比密西西比模型更小、更容易管理。
So we're looking at Bluestone Dam in Hinton, West Virginia. It's on the New River. A place that actually did flood recently. And the Army Corps' models helped to manage that flood. The Army Corps also uses the models as a public relations tool. The Corps invites people from local communities over to Erdick
所以我们正在看西弗吉尼亚州辛顿的布鲁斯通大坝。它位于新河上。一个最近确实发过洪水的河段。陆军工程兵团的模型帮助管理了那次洪水。陆军工程兵团还将这些模型用作公共关系工具。兵团邀请来自当地社区的人们来到埃尔迪克
so they can see how new projects like building new navigation channels or removing old dams will affect the area. Engineers at Erdick say they take community feedback and incorporate that into their designs. But here's the most surprising thing I learned about these physical models. The reason that engineers continue to rely on them is because today, in 2016, we still do not have the computers or the science to do all the things
这样他们就可以看到诸如建设新的航道或拆除旧水坝之类的新项目将如何影响该地区。埃尔迪克的工程师表示，他们会听取社区反馈并将其纳入他们的设计中。但关于这些物理模型，我学到的最令人惊讶的事情是。工程师们继续依赖它们的的原因是，今天，在2016年，我们仍然没有计算机或科学来完成所有这些事情
that physical models can do. There's actually this realm of human knowledge and of physical behavior and how the earth works that we don't understand. This is Stanford Gibson, a senior hydraulic engineer for the Army Corps. This is a guy with a PhD and three masters degrees, and even the math he can do isn't sufficient to fully describe what happens in a river. I think that there needs to be a little bit of scientific humility to say, well, maybe
物理模型能够做到的一切。实际上，人类知识、物理行为以及地球运作方式中，有这样一个领域是我们所不理解的。这是斯坦福·吉布森，陆军工程兵团的高级水利工程师。这是一个拥有博士学位和三个硕士学位的人，甚至他能做的数学运算也不足以完全描述一条河里发生的事情。我认为应该有一点科学的谦逊，去承认，也许
some of these processes are outside of our reach, or at least outside of the reach of our generation. Are we going to get there? Well, we'll get closer. Believe it or not, hydraulic engineering gets into some of the most complicated math there is. Allegedly, when Albert Einstein's son Hans that he wanted to study how sediment moves underwater, Einstein asked him why he wanted to work on something so complicated. The physics involved
其中一些过程超出了我们的能力范围，或者至少超出了我们这一代人的能力范围。我们能做到吗？嗯，我们会更接近。信不信由你，水利工程涉及到存在的最复杂的数学问题之一。据称，当阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的儿子汉斯说他想研究沉积物如何在水下移动时，爱因斯坦问他为什么想研究如此复杂的事情。其中涉及的物理学
happened on such a small scale that we still haven't built equations complex enough to capture them. And so Stanford Gibson, a world-class numerical modeler, is actually one of the most ardent supporters of physical modeling. Because a physical model doesn't require equations at all. The physical model will simulate the processes on its own. And even as Stanford Gibson develops new numerical models, the process is inherently tied to the natural world. When I started a new project, I go and I rent a kayak
发生在如此小的尺度上，以至于我们至今尚未构建出足够复杂的方程来捕捉它们。因此，斯坦福·吉布森这位世界级的数值模拟专家，实际上是物理模拟最坚定的支持者之一。因为物理模型根本不需要方程。物理模型将自行模拟这些过程。即使在斯坦福·吉布森开发新的数值模型时，这个过程也与自然界紧密相连。当我开始一个新项目时，我去租一艘皮划艇
and I float the river because there are too many processes that you don't understand that you can't represent in equations. For Stanford, the more time you spend on a river, the more you learn its secrets. Kind of like Mark Twain. And all those years he spent working on steamboats, learning to read the Mississippi, like a book. You know, did you ever read Mark Twain life on the Mississippi? I did. So you remember that whole, like, maybe a hundred pages near the beginning,
我在河上漂流，因为有太多的过程你不理解，无法用方程来表达。对斯坦福来说，你在一条河上花的时间越多，你就越能了解它的秘密。有点像马克吐温。他在轮船上度过的所有那些岁月，学会了像读书一样阅读密西西比河。你知道，你读过马克吐温的《密西西比河上的生活》吗？我读过。所以你还记得开头附近大约有一百页的篇幅，
where he's talking about the Mississippi for him was, like this magical, mystical thing, imbued with mystery, and that once he learned the river, that was lost to him forever. I remember that moment exactly because that is exactly not my experience of science. The idea that science demystifies the world, I just don't understand that.
他在那里谈到密西西比河对他来说就像是一个神奇的、神秘的事物，充满了神秘感，而一旦他了解了这条河，这一切就永远离他而去。我确切地记得那一刻，因为这完全不是我的科学体验。科学剥离了世界的神秘感这种观点，我实在无法理解。
I feel like the kind of deeper down the scientific rabbit hole I go, the bigger and grander and more magical the world seems. And the same goes for going down the scientific rabbit hole I go, the bigger and grander and more magical the world seems. And the same goes for going down the rabbit holes of history, and engineering, and mathematics, and design. If there's one thing I believe more than anything, is that knowledge creates wonder. 99% invisible was produced this week by Ryan Kyl, Sam Greenspan, and Delaney Hall, Wissery Fusef, Katie Mingle, Kurt Kohlstedt, Average Truffleman, and me Roman Mars.
我觉得我下科学的兔子洞越深，这个世界看起来就越大、越宏伟、越神奇。深入历史、工程学、数学和设计的兔子洞也是如此。如果说有什么是我最坚信不疑的，那就是知识创造惊奇感。本周的《99% Invisible》由瑞安·凯尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和德莱尼·霍尔制作，威里·菲塞夫、凯蒂·明格尔、库特·科尔斯特、平均特鲁夫曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同呈现。
Mark Twain was played by Ken Toich and Herbert Hoover Wissery Fusef. Allow the music in this episode came from some of our favorite favorite musicians, including Lullatone, Melodium, and Okakumi. You can get a full list at 99pi.org. This episode is part of PRX's Stories in Science Project, supported by the Alfred P. Sloan Foundation to enhance public understanding of science, technology, and economic performance.
马克·吐温由肯·托奇饰演，赫伯特·胡佛由威里·菲塞夫饰演。本集中的所有音乐均来自我们最喜爱的一些音乐家，包括 Lullatone、Melodium 和 Okakumi。你可以在 99pi.org 上获取完整列表。本集是 PRX“科学故事”项目的一部分，该项目得到阿尔弗雷德·P·斯隆基金会的支持，旨在增强公众对科学、技术和经济绩效的理解。
We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio tapio.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目。我们都在 Twitter、Instagram 和 Spotify 上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的照片和链接，并收听《99% Invisible》的所有剧集，你必须访问 99pi.org。电台塔皮奥。
From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。